i'm okay actually i can reach my home um  what we've actually been doing is just  trying to coordinate support for our  local firefighters because they have  been  inundated issued with fires  um across this area it's it's been  really really dreadful and obviously  there have been many many residents here  in hebron who have been displaced  have you ever had anything like this in  summer's gone by  never never and i've been watching your  coverage actually and it ha it's  heartbreaking for us all i've had  endless and endless residents that want  to support our local firefighters um and  police officers doing a fantastic job um  and it's just like watching a science  fiction film you know it's just  heartbreaking to know that you know it's  literally a few miles away from your own  doorstep